you'll be supporting well I think the
first thing to ask is what are the
qualities that we need that will see the
big issue is brexit and I think we need
candidates who will address this issue
with clarity not base their approach on
wishful thinking recognize the hard
realities I think we need candidates who
can communicate who can beep Jeremy
Corbyn and can unite the country I think
there are a number of good candidates
I've sat around the cabinet table I've
heard Michael go very impressive around
the cabinet table in setting out the
issues I think Matt Hancock is running
an excellent pro-business campaign but
I'm going to support Rory Stuart's I
think I've worked very closely with Rory
in terms of the Ministry of Justice I've
seen his ability to be both strategic
and on top of the details as a minister
he's a excellent communicator I think he
has got an ability to connect with
people I think he's got an ability to
bring people together in order to find a
way through the brexit impasse does it
and I think you can win a general I can
say it does he have an ability to be
elected leader of the Conservative Party
I mean on the numbers it doesn't look
like it well clearly Rory is an underdog
and in some respects he's not a
conventional politician and not a
conventional candidate but I think
there's some real strengths in that and
in my view is I want to vote for the
candidate who I think is best placed to
meet the tests that I've set out and I
think Rory does that I think as I say
there's some very good other candidates
as well so it's a difficult choice for
someone in my perspective but having
worked closely with Rory you know he is
a serious figure very very thoughtful
articulate I think has got an ability to
connect with the public and connect with
the people that we need to bring over to
ensure that we we can get we can break
this impasse and I think you'd be a very
good Prime Minister so it's what is his
solution to the brexit problem then that
you you find so attractive well I think
the first thing to say is that Rory
recognizes the the the choices that are
available and some of the consequences
of those choices and I think that is an
important starting point well he's
talked about how we can make use of
citizens assemblies to try to break that
through but I think it's it's it's
it's essentially they think the
qualities that he brings in terms and
ability to communicate bring people over
I think working with all sides of the
House of Commons and indeed I think he
would be respected within the European
Union and therefore able to make I think
more progress than others might be able
to do so I think he's I think he's a
strong candidate but as I say there are
some other very strong candidates there
as well I have seen I've seen watch from
you in the past
warning the Conservative Party about a
shift towards populism yes
Laurie Stewart clearly doesn't fall into
that category who does well I'm not
going to be here to be critical of any
of the candidates I'm sure you would but
you'll understand that I'm not going to
and also we're a very early stage in
this campaign but the point that I was
warning against is that if we seek to
narrow our sport essentially to a hard
brexit position that we we no longer
seek to be a broad church that we go
down a particular approach that I think
would mean we would struggle to win the
support of pro-business voters of
perhaps younger voters more liberal
voters who voted for us particularly in
2015 and in large parts of the country
whether it be London or Scotland all
parts of the Home Counties the
Conservative Party which has
traditionally been very strong would not
have the reach would not have the appeal
that we have had in the past but when
you say populist don't you actually mean
popular I mean Boris Johnson of course
isn't far far more popular with
grassroots rank-and-file conservatives
but than anyone else that's running for
the leadership well I think what I would
say in terms of the popularity of any
candidate is that I think we shouldn't
just look at a snapshot of where we are
today but look forward over a period of
time now if we box ourselves into saying
that we should leave the European Union
without a deal on the 31st of October I
have a concern that either we will do
that and find that there's significant
economic disruption
and the government would be I think very
unpopular as a consequence or
alternatively we end up if you like
letting down the public because for some
one reason or another that doesn't
happen and that would undermine trust in
those politicians who made big promises
that in fact we would leave without a
deal by the 31st of October so I think
you have to you have to look forward a
few months and see where we might be in
the autumn and I worry that we if we go
down a trajectory which is all about
leaving without a deal that we find
ourselves in that very difficult
situation in those circumstances I mean
we've talked about this in a few
occasions in the past and you haven't
been drawn but would you be able to
serve in the cabinet of someone who was
advocating No Deal as a serious option
only wouldn't be able to serve in a
cabinet that was if you like had as its
objective leaving without a deal I don't
think you can completely take it off the
table because the European Union might
refuse any kind of an extension or we
might find ourselves in that situation
so I accept that we should prepare for
it but if it is an objective and saying
you know No Deal is the right answer
I wouldn't support that policy and I
wouldn't be able to serve in a cabinet
that pursued that policy would you as
with Philip Hammond to just who
suggested the same would you in those
circumstances see yourself participating
in a in a vote of no confidence in the
leader no I I wouldn't be voted voting
in a no-confidence motion in the House
of Commons in a way that was going to
lead to a Jeremy Corbyn government I
don't think that is the right approach
but I do think there is a point about
saying whether the House of Commons
would support a strategy which is in
favor of No Deal I think there's a
question as to whether it would and with
John Bercow as Speaker whether there
would be a means of frustrating is so
which is which is why I think rather
than focusing on No Deal as as perhaps
some might want to do you we should try
to focus on how we can try to break the
impasse and I think there are a number
of candidates who are doing that and I
think that is sensible interesting
though that you haven't been swayed by
Michael Gough showing a little bit of
iron core in suggesting that you know he
would be prepared to delay brexit for a
year in order to get a delay in order to
get a deal done well I have a very
my opinion of Michael anyone who has sat
around the cabinet table in recent
months and heard the way in which he has
addressed these issues with great
honesty and great clarity he obviously
comes to it from the spective of having
led the vote leave campaign so he is a
committed brexit here so I'm very
impressed by Michael but as I as I say
Rory Stewart will have my vote in the
the first round whilst we have you
Donald Trump and coming to the United
Kingdom next week why did it need to be
a state visit well look I think it's
important that we have a good
relationship with the United States
there are most important security ally
Donald Trump as president we don't all
have to agree with everything he says or
does the style or the substance but it
is important that we have a good
relationship with the President of the
United States if we have a state visit
if that helps cement that good
relationship it's very important for us
it seems to me to ensure that the United
States is properly committed to NATO for
example with if that depends to a large
extent on the nature of our relationship
with the US and a state visit helps with
that relationship with the US then I
think that's what we should do it seems
to me that you're suggesting that our
kind of diplomatic efforts with the
United States are based on the idea that
Donald Trump might be swayed by dinner
at the queen-size well what I'm saying
is that if an event such as this helps
strengthen the United Kingdom's
relationship with the United States then
that is something that we should do and
you know it's not not unprecedented to
have a state visit so you know I think
that's that's no bad thing to do I just
want to ask you one last question before
we go on or on on on brexit I mean is it
possible for anyone who at least has
there's an option nor deal is it
possible for them to the unite the
Conservative Party well I don't want to
draw red lines on this sometimes perhaps
too many red lines get get drawn yeah
there are a lot of candidates I think
you want to unite the Conservative Party
but I think it's it's really important
that we are practical and pragmatic and
I do worry that there are some who say
let's just bring this all to an end
and No Deal we'll bring it to then No
Deal doesn't bring it to an end it just
means we then have to sort out the next
stages but having left the European
Union in really quite difficult
circumstances I didn't think that's the
right choice for the country